welcome to this video what's going I
cannot pronounce that someone someone
had had to explain to what this means i
think it's rushil name for for some
animal but have I really have forgotten
what it was ok we have a snake brain
only here now that's a funny opening
line Bishop d6 ok I play I played in a
very solid fashion they are not doing
any anything out of the ordinary as I
don't know the opening that well or not
at all hmm so ok let's just complete
development here then the bishop is
coming to a five and the in the snake
and the night very often to g6 night d
75 g 6 Jack ok at least I haven't spent
too much time here yes this will go to
see for most of the time so haha so now
I get an A five actually maybe I should
do that that the bishop is not even
coming to see form I am ok and light
will go to g6 ok a5 is always slight
liability here I wait wait wait I can go
on to something like 94 is this an idea
so that he has to go g5
I'm not sure but looks interesting okay
while sacrificing is not exactly i can
do this and maybe aim for f4f or later
Angie g5 cannot be a really ideal like I
mean definitely not so a fawn or
something else yeah come on let's let's
let's be let's play straightforward
chassis him if he takes pawn TX 96 I
will play a five and 94 yeah this is
this this cannot be survived I don't
don't believe it it may be has to go 96
now but then maybe Bishop d3 is good or
still 94 they're not not sure maybe we
should be three also allowing Queen h5
if he goes to g6 immediately yeah I
think this is the right choice
relatively speaking it's not it's not
nice anyway but probably what he has to
do if i play f5 now by the way it's also
dangerous Bishop takes and then this eve
for all 94 both good you for Queen
default trick I'd winter peas at the end
okay let's push this
not spending more time on it Bishop
takes e4 Queen d4 check greentech ctx
takes f5 takes 26 app that wins apiece
so he has to move the piece on g6 the
night and I don't know 97-94 looks
rather rather terrible yeah okay I'm
going to go night before here I think or
is queen is seven somehow saving him can
also take here first or Bishop d3 you
chose are also not stupid maybe mighty
494 Queenie 70 it's not so clear what my
reply is to that okay let's do this
first it still cannot really take it due
to the e4 pins
no I'm threatening 94 yeah if I go nitey
for now he will probably just sex the
exchange em probably another idea is
just to play eform come on let's do that
and let its night I mean this night is
now somewhat stranded here it has no
square this is more of a positional
approach one thing that might happen is
just bishop f 2 g-3 and it's it's lost
year the night has no square whatsoever
and that's also I this is in fact a good
idea I can try maybe bishop you one
check okay that's strange I mean I like
you to play for ship f2 really because
you know I'm winning the piece really
just just like like that black reserve
that it was lost I think anyway but why
it let's at least very critical I don't
know around here it starts to become
become at least hard to play food like
this f4 move is not easy to face and
he's really reckoned on the kingside a
computer wants to play Queen g7 near
stock fish as a precaution against f4
after that I think it gets it gets
really tricky I mean this is probably
down down right lost and yeah that
cannot be survived so this is right I am
computer once okay Bishop g4 which is
not bad definitely not and here and I am
a thief is given by the comp yeah that's
that's pretty comparable to what I did I
think yeah I mean after that he can he
can maybe do this secular exchange and
play rookie aid and this is getting kind
of messy
even I mean it's good for white probably
the computer likes white but it's it's
not so easy now I will lose III and it
gets messy and here I'm just following
this idea to move the bishop and play g3
and then edition ideas by the way bishop
you one night oops name not they're also
not what I wanted can I get rid of those
arrows please yes this idea nighty to
bishops III this would be fantastic yes
which places those two pieces switch
places and white is then probably
winning out with the bishop coming down
and while the computer is on from plus
one point six years this is losing the
peace straight away but I think it
wasn't it wasn't so great the snake bit
nonius is not is yeah probably not one
hundred percent correct but it's a it's
an interesting opening he maybe got
something wrong here with with his his
move orders um I think he should try to
maybe maybe try to prevent this nightie
for business or at least in the way it
did it happened in the game okay i hope
you liked it thanks for watching